hey Tyler Perry here yes and we are
doing the wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
so what happens when you google Tyler
Perry says it's Tyler Perry Oh Lord this
is dating taraji Henson no but and I
know the guy that she's dating and he's
pretty darn incredible so
yeah he's incredible and he's really a
saint to be put up is Tyler Perry buying
American Airlines I don't even know
where that came from somebody started
that just came up no I'm not buying
American Airlines one of the planes for
you there's one over you not buy an
American Airlines I don't even know
where that came from
is Tyler Perry and Katy Perry related
yes we are actually yeah this is this is
new if you go back and you look at the
lineage and the history of the Perry
family back in 1822 when the Perry's
Katie's family came over off a Plymouth
Rock who is whose - Roger piensas best
friend
JC JC drinketh oh she could totally play
Diana Ross so who is Suraj EP Henson's
mother who's your mama my mother is
Bernice Gordon what's taraji piensan
zodiac sign same as Tyler Perry's zodiac
sign it's Tyler Perry a billionaire yes
is Tyler Perry giving away money no what
is Tyler Perry's email address
it's taraji P Henson at gmail it's Tyler
Perry Christian yes I believe in Jesus
Christ I believe in God although I drink
and I cut sometimes pray buddy but God
is good okay is Tyler Perry dead dude
I'm sitting right here
is taraji P Henson Illuminati people
people really seriously y'all haters
call you mr. Roger P has his hair is
real it's real but a woman's head is
Roger B Hansen in the hospital no she's
right here we have - who is - Roger Joe
in the Madea movies
my daddy is Boris Mortensen and he
passed away in oh six Barcelona's God
God God bless and rest in peace yes why
is Tyler Perry and inspiration because
you can't well I did Tyler Perry change
his name because I Emmitt is my birth
name but it was associated with a lot of
yelling and screaming and horrible
things and I didn't want to be called by
that man's name so I changed money yeah
why is Tyler Perry famous no because I
have a loyal loving amazing audience who
have supported me and I love you nothing
why did Tyler Perry go to jail well I
did not pay a ticket it was a was a
speeding ticket and I didn't have the
money to pay it and about three years
after that I'm kidding I never been no
jail get out of here is taraji P Henson
biracial no you don't know we're all
about race well mixed well we are but I
is - Roger P Henson from Cameroon
actually yes my mother's mother's reach
are from camera is Taurasi P Henson
Greek she does look like a Greek god
turn to the left
you look like a Greek goddess is - Roger
B Henson a singer next please yes she is
she can really sing okay does Tyler
Perry have a brother yes and
he is 10 years my junior I'm gonna do
the gripping you always do the repeat is
Tyler that's our very own an island yes
yes I have a beautiful and taraji spin
there does Tyler Perry own a production
company yes
Tyler Perry played Joe and Mugsy and
movies no that's me okay you rip it you
rip a hole how did your GP Henson become
famous
it's a Rajiv Indian some win the Golden
Globes
yes I did duster ah GP Henson's person
have a fur coat that he bought in
Wakanda